uh all smiles on the local election
Trail but other parts of Labor's
campaign are less good-natured and could
leave a mark
controversial attack ads published three
weeks ago accusing the prime minister of
not wanting child abusers to go to
prison speaking to Sophie Ridge the
labor leader said he believed this
inflammatory accusation was true and
stood by the ads this idea that somehow
you can ship in a new prime minister
we've had five of them now in the last
13 years and but somehow he doesn't bear
responsibility they have broken our
criminal justice system so it is
unforgivable
do you take personal responsibility then
for every child abuser who escaped
prison while were you a director of
public prosecutions I took full
responsibility for every decision of the
crown prosecution does that mean that
you don't think that people should go to
jail you don't think rapists should go
to responsibility is that what you're
saying I'll tell you how that worked
when I was director of public
prosecutions it meant that when we
succeeded in some very important
prosecutions I took the credit for that
on behalf of the organization where we
got it wrong I carried the can
lead prosecutor for five years kirst
armor apologized in 2013 for
organizational shortcomings in relation
to the Jimmy Savile investigation he's
also been criticized for changes some
say made it easier for men to be falsely
accused of abusing children at the core
of these ads is the suggestion that
Rishi sunak should be held personally
responsible for the failures of the last
13 years but if you apply that same
logic to secure starma it means he can
be attacked for any problems that
occurred in organizations that he's LED
and that presents opportunities for the
conservatives to try and undermine the
labor leader
something this cabinet minister
acknowledged while insisting his party
will keep it clean if he's going to
apply his own argument then he has to
say that he's guilty of the same things
as he's accusing the prime minister of I
just don't think it's a very good way to
conduct politics you should focus on the
issues and the prime ministers
demonstrated on this subject grooming
gang said he's actually very tough on it
and I think that's how people will judge
him
for the smaller parties who are no
strangers to aggressive campaigning the
prospect of all-out war between the
Tories and labor could bring benefits
there are times when opposition parties
do want to cut through where there are
issues that we want to talk about which
the government doesn't want to talk
about
um but what I hope that liberal
Democrats have shown is that we try to
do that in a positive way Thursday's
local elections will give an indication
of how various political strategies are
panning out
[Applause]
labor eager to show a party on the path
to power but bold campaigning can carry
big risk Rob pal Sky News in Westminster